I've got a great book recommendation for
you today
this is recently I've been recommending
more sort of dense academic type books
this is a total departure from that not
doesn't mean it's a bad book it's a
great book actually the book is called
never split the difference by Chris vos
Chris vos is a former FBI hostage
negotiator okay his experience is
amazing and this is a book where he uses
his experience doing hostage
negotiations to really tell us so much
about how people can sometimes be
convinced how people can be negotiated
with and if you think oh this sounds
like a sales book like if you're in
business sales or something like that
no no by no means this is a book that I
found interesting with regard to
interviewing and the types of
interviewing that we do on the show this
is a book that could be really
informative in terms of relational
conversations that you have with your
significant other or family or kids or
parents or whatever this is a book that
can be really useful even in just
navigating normal buying situations that
the average person is in it's sort of a
combination of the behavioral economics
psychology motivational interviewing and
also sprinkled in with law enforcement
and it's super super interesting yeah
because it's about using tactics to
convince people and get them to come to
your side it reminds me a lot about the
torture debate that we have going on in
this country now because Donald Trump
wants to bring it back seemingly right
and his defense secretary general mattis
advised you probably shouldn't do that
the carrot approach works a lot better
no doubt about it and the the
differences that this discussion of the
carrot versus the stick approach plays a
really big role in how FBI hostage
negotiation techniques have evolved over
time and it's moved from more of a stick
approach to a carrot approach it's
something Chris Voss was sort of in the
middle of any talks about how the FBI I
wouldn't say slowly I wouldn't say
quickly but deliberately moved more from
stick approach to the carrot approach
and sort of how strategic empathy
impacts that approach as well and I'm
sure the public is not too happy about
that because they would think why are
you treating these criminals so nicely
but it turns out that's how you get what
you want in the end you need an
evidence-based approach and a results
based approach and if the idea of being
nice to suspects or whoever is sort of
ideologically unappealing but it gives
us the results that we want in terms of
national security or better outcomes in
hostage situations why wouldn't we take
it right are we concerned with its sort
of the difference between a pragmatist
and an ideologue the ideologue says we
shouldn't be mean to people that we
suspect did something bad the pragmatist
says we should do what leads to the best
outcomes for whatever we're trying to
accomplish yeah it can be quite
controversial too because remember Dylan
roof a Charleston shooter he was given
Burger King before he testified or not
testified but spoke to police yeah
and that was you know that blew up
because if it was a black perpetrator he
probably wouldn't have been given the
same tree there was a racial angle to it
and there there was yeah a lot of
interesting stories there so this is a
really quick read I think it's 200 pages
and it goes pretty quickly it's probably
just I don't know you might be able to
read this book in like five six hours
total you can do it over a weekend it's
really good never split the difference
by Chris Voss you can check it out along
with all my other recommendations at
david pakman.com slash recommendations
and particularly in the midst of the
YouTube ad boycott which has crushed the
revenue of our program anything you buy
using the Amazon links at david
pakman.com slash recommendations will
support the work that we're doing you
can also use david pakman.com slash
amazon for anything you want to buy on
amazon not my recommendations and of
course I know I've mentioned this before
you can go to patreon.com/scishow to
contribute directly to the program I am
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show a lot of
great stuff coming up today glad you're
with us on this Friday